[Música]
tuve el momento hablar de revista de
prensa en directo américa ya está
conmigo lista en el estudio de rosa
pérez más euros a bienvenida feliz
mañana vamos a hablar por supuesto de lo
que avanzábamos previamente la polémica
en reino unido por las fiestas del
gobierno durante el confinamiento con la
última novedad estos rosas la
celebración del cumpleaños de nada menos
que el primer ministro boris johnson
parábamos como entonces les trata la
prensa británica veamos este artículo
deja recall en the song que titula
pastel y comer buenos días raúl exacto y
es que esta nueva noticia no la
celebración del cumpleaños de boris
johnson en el 2020 cuando cumplía 56
años ha puesto en bandeja este titular
con esta frase hecha inglesa de tener el
pastel y comerlo no en referencia a que
no se puede tener todas las cosas buenas
y dejar de lado las malas en este caso
pues a saltarse las restricciones que
estaban impuestas para el resto de la
población y salir impunes de este
escándalo no en referencia pues a boris
johnson y a su gobierno pero sigamos
porque toda la prensa británica hoy está
hablando de eso
ahora rosa con the time s con este
artículo de oliver right here is dead
man boris johnson celebró una fiesta de
cumpleaños durante el encierro en el
número 2 exacto porque una vez más los
detalles están la clave raúl porque aquí
digamos que entran en conflicto dos
versiones mientras que el gobierno no
downing street está intentando defender
que se trató de un acto más o menos
improvisado en que básicamente las
personas que estaban ahí trabajando pues
se comieron tarta y contaron cumpleaños
feliz haciendo un poco como de forma
imprevista pues resulta que quien
convocó esta reunión para comer la tarta
fue la mujer de boris johnson y 30
funcionarios de downing street
reportan haber recibido esta invitación
y entre los presentes estaban no sólo la
mujer de boris johnson carry simon's
sino también el decorador de interiores
de la pareja así ese rosa y cerramos
esta cuestión todo ese tema con el texto
de the gardian exacto porque como es ya
un poco complicado seguir la cuenta de
todas las fiestas
y reuniones que se saltaban las reglas
sanitarias pues the gardian ha hecho un
recopilatorio no de todas las a con
todos los acontecimientos que ya forman
parte de este escándalo conocido como
party gate y digamos de momento del
medio británico cuenta 15 reuniones que
violaron pues las normas impuestas como
decíamos a toda la población británica
entre estas 15 celebraciones en más de
una de más de dos y más de tres se
encontraba el primer ministro boris
johnson vamos a ver qué pasa qué pasa
con este informe que está redactando la
alta funcionaria su grey y que revelará
sus conclusiones pues ya próximamente
también a destacar que la policía
británica finalmente se ha decidido a
investigar los hechos y vamos a ver cómo
queda pues el papel de boris johnson al
frente del gobierno pica y se extiende
rosa todo este tema del pari gate en
reinounido cambiamos pero seguimos con
the gardian que aborda el usa la
tecnología del tag de apple con fines de
seguimiento y espionaje de personas
efectivamente esta tecnología pues ya se
sospechaba que podría ser usada con los
fines que no eran los previstos por la
compañía cuando fue lanzada al mercado
este año 2021 recordemos los stacks son
estos pequeños localizadores que apple
sacó al mercado con el objetivo de pues
ayudarnos a encontrar pues las llaves
pues el vehículo pues ahí donde lo
colocaremos no hay vínculo podría estar
vinculado con los dispositivos apple de
las personas que los tengan sin embargo
la policía de eeuu y de alrededor del
mundo según comenta este artículo está
recibiendo cada vez más denuncias de
personas que detectan ser espiadas o
seguidas mediante pues estos objetos no
otras personas pues les han colocado los
airbags en el bolsillo en el bolso o en
el coche y si bien lo que dice este
artículo es que si detectamos estar
siendo seguidos mediante esta tecnología
lo que debemos hacer es ir a informar a
la policía y no llegar hasta nuestra
casa también señala este artículo que en
muchos casos pues la policía no está
respondiendo de forma efectiva a estas
denuncias
sin embargo queríamos enmarcar tal y
como nos señala este artículo
o sea hechos en el siguiente dato y es
que 75 millones de personas son víctimas
de este tipo de acoso en eeuu cada año y
uno de cada cuatro de estos casos son
entre seguimientos que funcionan basados
en estas tecnologías rosa y vamos ahora
con un reportaje de kenny cabrera y en
natalia romero para el planeta el futuro
del diario el país titula el lazio el
otra forma de violencia machista
que se se va con las dominicanas rosa si
es un reportaje con muchas fuentes y
muchos datos entre los cuales que este
año pasado el 14 por ciento de las
víctimas que ingresó en las unidades de
quemados intensivos del país fueron
rociadas con este químico y el 98 por
ciento de ellas eran mujeres cuando
hablamos de este químico del ácido del
hacemos referencia a una
combinación de ácido sulfúrico con ácido
clorhídrico y disolvente de pintura de
vehículos pues entre otras sustancias
pues una quemadura con este mes y llega
a provocar afectaciones a los huesos y
órganos vitales puede causar ceguera y
deformación e irreversible del rostro de
la parte del cuerpo que sea afectada
además pues las personas también en este
caso tal y como señala este artículo
sufren un estigma físico no por razones
pues evidentes a lo largo de sus vidas
lo que se suma a que con una falta de
acompañamiento pues tanto de las
autoridades del estado como de ongs de
estas personas se quedan pues apartadas
un poco de la vida civil aparte no de
todas las lesiones físicas irreparables
en muchos casos y si bien tal y como
destaca este artículo el código penal de
república dominicana considera los
ataques con esta nueva peligrosa mezcla
de agentes corrosivos como acto de
tortura y barbarie las distintas
supervivientes señalan que en muchos
casos pues sus agresiones quedan en la
total impunidad no por una falta de
inacción policial de coordinación entre
las autoridades y como señalábamos
también una falta de acompañamiento de
las supervivientes de hecho es artículo
señala el caso de dos mujeres que fueron
agredidas con esta sustancia y que
llegaron a los tribunales pero por sus
propias acciones lamentable esa
violencia contra las mujeres rosas
gracias por toda la información nos
vemos mañana con más revista de prensa
nosotros vamos a pasar ahora a hablar
con esta primera mitad al día
[Música]